The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, we're going
to be talking about something
a little bit away from
the game of poker, per se,
and more about looking at
poker as an investment.
The conceit here is
that, to some extent,
you're either a winning
poker player now,
or eventually you'll get there.
So this is looking at now that
you have these alpha streams,
these streams of
positive EV that you
can pick which ones you
want to embrace, how do you
balance out?
How do you look at your
future, given that this is now
an option you hold?
Cash game here
just means anything
that's not a tournament,
where tournament is a poker
structure where you buy
in, and with money, you
receive tournament
chips, and you only
get money to the extent
that you survive longer
than someone else, where
the person with all
the chips in the end
wins some set piece,
not necessarily all their chips.
Whereas a cash game is one
such that each chip has
a specific value, like you're
actually bedding real dollars,
and you can enter or
leave whenever you like.
So in cash games, chips are
effectively literal money,
so the more chips you win,
the more money you win.
Whereas in tournaments, all
that matters is the position
you finish.
When we talk about the
Independent Chip model,
we'll talk about
when those diverge.
The second point is about that,
where Chip EV, like literally
having more chips,
in a cash game
is directly related to the
amount of money you make.
If you're making a
decision that results
in you having more chips,
you make more money
in the long run.
Whereas in a tournament, it's
a little bit more complicated.
They're congruent,
and they generally
trend in the same direction.
But in some particular
cases, what's
something that's
positive Chip Ev
may be either positive or
negative in terms of Dollar EV,
and we'll talk about
that in a little bit.
Cash games-- you can come
and go whenever you want.
That makes them very liquid.
If you're a big
cash game player,
you can generally grind
out your hourly win rate
whenever you want,
especially online.
There's a little bit of
overhead when you play live,
but cash games are much easier
to just come and go with regard
to kind of executing your skill.
With tournaments.
you get all your EV from
winning, from lasting long,
so you're generally stuck.
The better you are, the
longer these tournaments take,
and you have to kind of
be there for the long run
and generally plan
to last a long time.
In cash games, you can buy
in as many times as you want.
Like if you're in a cash game
with a lot of bad players
and you get knocked out,
you can just buy back in.
It's like it never happened.
With a tournament, if
you're at a tournament
with a lot of bad players,
and you get knocked out
the first hand because
you get unlucky,
you never get to redo
that for most tournaments.
You always get kind of
a new field of players,
and you don't have
the opportunity
to reenter a tournament.
Your only choice is to enter
at the first time or not.
Cash games have fixed blinds.
The situation that
you're in when you start
is generally the situation
you're always going to be in,
so you don't need to factor in
having a different size stack.
Presumably, you're
always going to have
at least the maximum
buy-in or more.
Whereas in tournament
situations,
you're going to
be short-stacked.
People at your table
are going to have
a widely different stack size.
In cash games, you have
a single table selection,
which is you get to see
the nine people that you're
going to play against.
And you can watch
them, and you can
see if eight people call
pre-flop in a cash game,
you know that probably seven
of those people are bad,
and you can just enter that game
and play against those eight
or nine people-- totally fine.
Whereas for tournaments,
because you're only
playing against nine other
people in the tournament
of a field of say,
like 100, you only
really get to target
groups of people.
You can identify an
audience of people
who would enter that
tournament and then get
an idea of what the average
person you'll play against
will be, but you
can enter tournament
with 90 fish and 10 pros and be
at a table of 10 pros to start.
So that adds a little
bit of variance.
It also adds some
complexity in trying
to get a read at your
table and kind of make
that jive with your read of
what the average player should
be for that tournament.
Like the World Series
of Poker is typically
a tournament that has
like 60% fish, 40% percent
pros nowadays.
But a lot of tables end up
like eight pros and two fish,
and that creates a
much different type
of situation for you than
if you were at a table that
was primarily new players.
As I said before, cash
games have higher liquidity.
The best kind of career
you can make in poker
is being really good at
a cash game, because you
can go anywhere and play those.
You can play as
long as you want.
Like if you only have two
hours and you're in Vegas,
you can grind out
pretty confidently
like $150 in EV, no problem.
Whereas in a tournament,
it's much more uncertain
how long it'll take
you to capture that EV
and how long you might be
obligated to stick around.
For what's considered
normal win rates,
cash games are considered
lower variance.
Tournaments are considered
higher variance.
If you're winning at cash
games, you're crushing it,
but it's much, much harder to
win at cash games, at least
at the medium high stakes.
It's for this reason--
it's because anyone who's
a loser at a cash game knows
it immediately and drops out
really quickly.
Whereas in tournaments,
some of the big name pros
are probably losers
at this point,
they just don't know it yet.
Because you can go
years before you
find out whether you're
actually a winner
or a loser at big tournaments.
Let's talk about the
tournament life cycle.
The early game is going to be
everything before the bubble.
So it's going to be like the
first 90% of eliminations
in the tournament will
be in the early game,
although because of
how tournaments work,
that ends up being like half
the tournament in terms of time.
But you get the idea anyway.
Play during the early game is
very similar to cash games.
There's no ICM.
There's no difference
in the value of chips
early on, because when
you have 1,000 chips,
and you need 100,000
to win the tournament,
a difference of 50 chips
isn't that big of a deal.
The difference in value
of chips doesn't really
matter that much, which is why
I'm saying that Tournament Chip
EV is approximately
equal to real Dollar EV,
so make decisions as if it
were a normal cash game.
In addition, your
playing style is
going to be entirely
influenced by your stack size.
Having the same
proportional stack size
later in the early
game, you'll make
the same types of decisions.
I'm defining different zones of
play based on your stack size.
If your M is less
than 2, I'm calling
that the dead zone,
Harrington called it that.
2 to 8 is the steal period.
8 to 12 is the steal
re-steal period,
and we'll explain
what that is later.
12 to 30 is the value-betting
zone, and then 30 or more
is a set-mining zone.
Let me talk about tempo before
we get into what exactly
those things are.
The most important
thing about tournaments
with regard to
how it's different
than a cash game is
getting the speed
right, like getting your
aggression at the right level.
Doyle Brunson used to
say "never get caught
speeding in a tournament."
What that means is
don't get caught
being way too aggressive way
too early on, and by early on,
I mean when you have
a big chip stack.
So you need to win
coin flips, like you
will have to win several
hands when you're behind
to win a tournament.
So what you should
do is make sure
that when you're
not in coin flips,
you slowly grow
your stack, and you
avoid flipping
when you don't have
to so that when you
actually do flip,
you end up with more chips.
Like those small
differences are the things
that are multiplied all
throughout the tournament
to make you-- instead of
like 1% chance of winning
a tournament, like 3% or 4%.
That's where your edge
really materializes.
The dead zone-- being in
the dead zone is terrible.
It's much worse than
half of having 4M.
You should only
ever be in the zone
because you lost the last hand,
and you had slightly more chips
than that guy.
Because this is a
really bad situation
to be in, because you
have no fold equity.
So fold equity is
where your value
is going to come from,
because you're not
going to win a lot of
showdowns in a tournament,
and a lot of your EV
from the tournament
is going to come
from fold equity.
So if you have less
than 2M, you're
going to bet like
pre-flop, and the big blind
is going to call you without
even looking at his hand, which
means you have no fold
equity-- like you basically
have to win a showdown
to get back into it,
and that's a really
bad situation.
You want to get out
of the dead zone
before you have to
pay a big blind,
and then you're
going to be stuck
on whatever hand you get there.
The reason is you
want to be able to get
your fold equity back.
If you're under 1M under
any circumstance-- so never,
never do that.
Call any two cards
before you get to 1M.
Why?
Because if you have 1M,
and then you double up,
you still are in the dead
zone, like you're basically
at least one coin flip behind
being in a terrible situation.
So enter any sort of coin flip
to avoid getting below 1M.
So a lot of your value is going
to come from this steal period,
and by steal, I mean
stealing blinds.
When you have between 2
an 8M, your only decision
is to go all in or fold.
Because every time
you steal the blinds,
and the blinds are
really valuable to you,
you increase your stack
by like 20% or 30%--
like that's a big deal.
That's probably more
than your equity
from actually going to showdown.
Unless you literally have
aces, that's probably
better than any
sort of edge you're
going to have by getting called.
So find out who doesn't
protect their blinds
and steal from them.
You should've been reading
people early in the tournament
to find out who's a
pushover-- like they're
going to be your best
friend, because you're going
to steal blinds from them.
On the converse,
pretend like you're
someone who defends their
blind, because if you get
walked-- if everyone folds
to your big blind-- you
just get one
additional M for free.
But don't actually
do it, because you
don't want to see a showdown.
It's a bit of a game of chicken,
and I will actively pretend,
like I will tell a
person I will actively
defend my blinds--
because it's not binding,
and you can do that-- and then
just think about whatever hand
I have and then fold.
You should still be calling
at a very tight range,
but to the extent that
you can convince them not
to push into you, it's almost as
good as the stealing yourself.
So avoid showdowns
if at all possible.
A lot of your hands are going
to be played in this period,
and the most important
thing you can do
is find opportunities to steal.
Don't get into showdowns.
Don't call unless you think
you're like a 70% favorite.
And it's related to
the Gap Theory, which
is by Sklansky, which says to
call a hand, to call it all in,
you need a much stronger
hand than to push.
Why?
Because when you push, when
you bet, you have full equity,
and when you call, you don't.
And that's the difference.
Like you can push with any two
cards in a lot of situations,
but you need to have
a good hand to call.
So you're here your goal here is
to keep your head above water.
Don't fall below
2, and preferably
get into like the 10M
period, either by doubling up
or by stealing.
So if you steal
three hands in a row,
you have 11M, if you're at 8.
That's the idea, here.
And then once you're
at 11M, you're
in a much more
interesting situation.
So this steal,
re-steal period is
when everyone is
trying to steal blinds,
except you have the equity
such that if you get re-raised,
you can fold.
What will happen is
people bet into you,
and you have to
re-pop them sometimes.
And then like you have
to identify who's going
to re-pop you and avoid them.
Here's the idea.
If you steal a bet with like
2M, and if he re-raises you
with 6M, you're like marginally
to call any two cards.
Then if you have an M of 5,
for example, you fall below.
If you have a 27%
equity, it's a good call,
meaning any two cards, because
you're at least 70%-30%
basically all the time.
Whereas if you have an
M of 12 and he pushes,
you have to have a
40% chance of calling,
like you can actually fold
this, and that's good,
it gives you more optionality.
The Value Betting Zone is
where you might actually
get to see a flop, and
you have to plan for that.
Your hand, pre-flop, is
actually valuable to the extent
it hits the flop, not like it
is when you have lower M, where
your hand's going to be
valuable to the extent
that you're likely to
be winning pre-flop.
So this play in 15M to 30M
is very similar to what
a cash game play is like.
So you're probably going
to see a bunch of flops,
and we're going to
plan accordingly.
You still don't want
to flat call pre-flop.
When you play a hand, you
want to be the aggressor.
You want to raise when
you have a good hand.
You want to fold when
you have a bad hand.
I'm going to call this
Flop, Turn, River, Play,
but I really mean it's play
when you have enough ships
to actually see the flop.
What you should do is
not play that many hands,
but when you play hands,
play them aggressively.
So the standard
bet here is going
to be 3 big blinds,
plus one big blind
for every caller before you.
So if everyone folded
before you, you bet 3.
If two people call before you,
you bet 5, 5 times a big blind.
All your bets should be big.
They should be big, big
portions of the pot.
2/3 is an OK number.
If you think the person
is particularly weak,
you can bet the pot.
First, we're going
talk about pre-flop.
When your M is high,
your value comes
from having a good
hand on the flop.
I still don't care
about the river.
If you do this right,
you're probably
not even going to
reach the river
by the time someone is all in.
We're only worried
about the extent
that your hand is
valuable on the flop.
Depending on your
position, this is
what I'm recommending
your opening range is,
where I'm saying you're opening
by raising to three big blinds.
So I'm saying that if
you're an early position,
you should really only do this
with like the top 5% of hands,
which is 10s or Ace-Queen,
suited, or Ace-King.
The difference in suitedness
actually matters there.
If you're first to
act, any other hand,
you should fold,
which is obviously
the majority of
hands, because you
have the least
amount of information
now-- like you might
be up against someone
with another strong hand, now.
And then on like
every card hereafter,
you're going to be in
the worst position.
So to win in that position, to
be profitable in that position,
you need to already
have a really good hand.
To the extent that you have the
option to just not play a hand,
it seems to make sense that you
would prefer not playing hands
when you're in a bad position.
So that's why that's
a really tight range.
When you get to
middle position--
so maybe like four
people to act after you--
you could widen up a little bit,
which a lot of you might think
is still very tight
range-- and it is.
This might be close
to like 15%, where
you have 8s or Ace-Jack,
and maybe, King-Queen.
Every other hand, you
should be folding.
Like that's your
range for raising out
of any sort of middle position.
And then it makes
it easy, because you
can imagine what type
of flop you either hit
or don't hit, here.
So if you're facing a
raise, what I recommend
is you just move
everything up one.
So if you're facing a raise
in early or middle position,
then you can play 10s,
Ace-Queen, Ace-King,
and if you're late, then you
can start playing like Ace-Jack.
So when it comes to
a flop, by this time,
you will have raised
pre-flop, and you are now
the aggressor in the hand.
So if you were the aggressor,
you should bet 2/3 of the pot.
That works a lot
more often than you
would think, even among people
who know what a seed bet is.
Then the break-even,
based on our formula,
is going to be 2/3
divided by 5/3, or 40%.
This is what I'm recommending
in terms of tiers.
This Tier 1 is a
King-high flush,
like I'm giving you a
little bit of leeway,
there, where you
don't need to have
literally the Ace-high flush.
But if you have the
King-high flush,
you can go broke for 30M.
In addition, the
literal top straight.
So if the board is 4,
5, 6, and you have 7, 8,
you can consider that Tier 1.
And this is only going to be
relevant on an unpaired board.
Why?
Like, what does a
paired board mean?
STUDENT: Somebody's got a flush.
STUDENT: Somebody [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It means a
full house is possible.
So if a full house is
possible, it basically
makes your hand worse than six
more hands that are possible.
Like a flush or a
straight on a paired
board would be
considered Tier 2.
Like if they're betting
aggressively into you,
and you have an Ace-high
flush, you might be ahead.
But then if they're
raising you, then I
would be very worried about you
being up against a full house.
So I would bet those
much less aggressively,
and then I would only bet
the Ace-high flush, here.
Like if you have a King-high
flush on that board,
there are all sorts of
hand that can beat you.
In addition, I'm saying
if you have what--
like the fourth best flush,
here, you can bet it,
but you can't raise it, really.
You can't raise it if they raise
into you, because that just
gives them too
many opportunities
to have a hand that
would actually beat you.
So a 10-high flush isn't bad.
You shouldn't fold it.
And you're not really
drawing, but you
should understand
that it doesn't
have four bets of value.
It only really has
two bets of value,
either a bet and their
raise, which you'll call.
Or if they bet, you can raise
them, and that's generally it.
And that's obviously
on an unpaired board.
This also counts a second
straight-- so a straight
where you don't have
the top two cards,
but you have two cards that
give you a straight that
are slightly lower.
In addition, bottom
set-- I would put here
in addition to any two pair.
So two pair is crushed by
a set, and then bottom set
is also crushed by any set.
It has the same problem.
So I'm calling this
Tier 2, and I'm saying
that's good for like two bets.
Tier 3 is an Overpair.
So if you have a pair of Jacks,
and the flop comes 2, 3, 4,
or something that is a
little bit less correlated,
like 2, 3, 10.
Like an Overpair is good.
It's slightly better
than Top-Pair Top-Kicker,
because you beat
Top-Pair Top-Kicker.
And then Top-Pair
Good-Kicker, I'm saying
is also Tier 3, where you
might be able to take it down.
Like if you bet, and they
call, you might still
be ahead if they're drawing.
But if you bet, and
they raise, you're
probably behind,
and should treat it
like you're drawing thereafter.
Then all these
hands, which you guys
might have previously thought
were good hands, are not.
They're just going to be
called drawing hands-- so
Top-Pair Bad-Kicker,
Mid or Bottom Pair,
or a Pocket Pair
that's not an Overpair.
So if you have 5s, when
the board is 2, 6, 7.
So by the Turn
and the River, all
your turns, like they're
already going to be big pots.
You don't need to
worry about extracting
additional bets on the Turn.
So in general,
try to figure out,
based on his action, what are
the possible groups of hands
that he could have here.
And in general, like that's it.
By the time you're
on the Turn, there
aren't like going to
be that many more bets.
So usually on the Turn, it's
either like go all in or fold.
Then hopefully you're
going to be in a situation
where you played it
right previously, where
you're going to have a better
idea of whether to do that.
Bubble play is going
to be around 20% to 10%
of the field left.
If we're saying that 10%
of the field makes money,
we're saying that
around 10% more
is when like everyone at every
table thinks that oh, like they
have a pretty good chance of
making money at some point.
So they change
around a little bit.
This is when ICM
starts mattering.
This is when your
decisions to win more chips
may not necessarily be the
maximal decision with regard
to winning money.
And it's when players
who are probably not
very comfortable with
the amount of stakes
that they're playing for start
to make really big mistakes.
Typically, the bad
players around the bubble
will be a little bit too
tight, like if you're
playing in the
World Series, you'll
see that like there
are 250 people left,
and 240 people get $12,000,
and everyone else gets zero.
And they're going
to say like OK,
maybe I don't need to
worry about increasing
my chances of getting first
place by half a percent
if it means that
I'm putting myself
at risk of getting zero now.
Like they weigh that little
jump in money quite a bit,
and as a result, they play
a little bit too tight.
Then the general-- at
least as of a couple years
ago-- the consensus was that
how you do during this bubble
period basically
determines how deep you're
going to go during
the tournament,
because this is when the
amateurs make the biggest
mistakes.
So if you're a player who likes
to exploit those mistakes,
this is when you're going to--
a good player can just crush it.
Like he can be
much more than 50%
to double up during this
period by just identifying
weaker players who don't want to
get knocked out for any reason
and just bullying them around.
So there are two types of
meta-game going on now,
just so you know.
This was a conventional belief--
"the average amateur player
is way too tight."
But then once everyone
realized that,
it became the opposite, where
the average amateur player
was way too aggressive.
Because once the first
one gets priced in,
then everyone starts
to be too aggressive,
because everyone
wants to do what
good players do on the bubble.
You could probably identify
your table pretty quickly
around this time,
whether you see
weaker players making really
bad calls or really bad folds.
That will kind of
give you an idea
of what situation you're in.
To the extent you can
bully people around,
but to the extent that other
people are bullying you,
you don't need to
necessarily push them back.
Let's talk about ICM.
The Independent Chip
Model is highlighting
when the chip value
diverges from your dollar
value in the tournament.
So Chip-EV, which
is a C, here-- how
it's different than
Dollar-EV in tournaments.
It's related to the
chance of you ending up
in certain payout spots.
That's why it's
particularly nonlinear.
Rather, when the first
place gets everything,
Chip-EV goes Dollar-EV,
because you eventually just
have to win all the chips.
And to the extent
it brings you closer
to winning all the chips, your
expectation for the tournament
is a little bit higher.
But when payouts are steep,
it gets a little bit more
complicated, because
in some situations,
surviving a little bit
longer has a material dollar
difference and getting more
chips in that situation
may not be as
important as surviving.
And we'll go through examples.
The Dollar-EV is not symmetric.
There's curvature.
So there's this idea of
convexity, where when you win,
you always lose in
this kind of situation,
because when you
win a lot of chips,
those chips go down
in value over time.
And when you lose chips, those
chips are really valuable.
So it makes your
marginal threshold
for making a risky
decision much higher.
In addition, when you factor
in actual utility of money,
it's even worse, where
clearly big upsides
are less good than protecting
against big downsides.
That's kind of the idea there.
Losing hurts more than winning.
Let's just go through
an example of this,
and hopefully this
will make it intuitive.
Say that we're playing
in this situation.
It was whatever, like a
100-person tournament that
was a $20 buy-in, and we're
down to the final four people,
and we have 2,500 chips each,
and these are the payouts,
where first gets a grand, second
gets $600, and third gets $400.
If we look at player
Adam, what's his equity?
Like what's his expected dollar
amount in this tournament,
assuming that everyone is
approximately equal skill,
which is the underlying
assumption here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it should be
like just 25% of the whole pot,
because he has 25% of the chips.
The whole pot is $2,000, so
I expect that his EV is $500.
And it is.
So everyone has a $500 EV.
But say that we're
in a situation where
Adam and David go into
a coin flip, and then
Adam beats David.
Intuitively, what do you think
Adam's equity should change to?
I would imagine you would
think that he just gets
the equity from David,
because those 2,500 chips are
worth $500 in equity
in the tournament.
So when this happens, how
does the equity change?
You could run it
through a poker tracker,
and I'll go through the kind
of rudimentary math for it.
You might think that Adam
now has $1,000 in EV,
and these guys have $500 in EV.
And like really,
you should think
those guys shouldn't have
gain from this happening,
because the pot
size doesn't change,
and they don't even
change in chip value.
But in actuality, Adam
only gains $266 of equity
for doubling up here,
and these guys actually
gain $100 from that happening.
Let me show you why that is.
Let's look at the
deltas of these payouts.
This is worth $400, and
then this is worth $200,
and getting to first is
worth an additional $400.
So we originally have
$500 of value here,
but now that one person's out,
everyone's guaranteed what?
Like certainly, when
someone has zero chips,
what's their equity
in this tournament?
It should be this, right?
$400-- like they already
are guaranteed $400 of chips.
OK, so now that
everyone has $400,
we're just allocating
the remainder of this.
We're deciding who gets
this remaining $600.
So you can see that
these guys have
a 25% chance of getting
that remaining $600,
which is why they
have just about $150
more than that $400 number.
So that's where it comes.
The reason this is is because
the winner does not eventually
get all of the equity, like
the winner doesn't end up
with $2,000.
He ends up with
$1,000, which is a less
valuable than adding up all
the equities from every player.
Really, he's giving value out
to the second and third place
player.
So that first spot is
probably the worst value
when it comes to your equity per
chip, because if it were winner
take all, then the
equity would be flat,
and then who would care?
But the fact that
he's giving money
to players who didn't have
all the chips in the end
caused that first
place to be really bad.
So since Adam is really
close to first place,
he's getting hurt the most.
You would think like fair value
would be $1,000, but he's not.
He's well short of it.
Whereas these guys are
just gaining from it,
because they're most likely
place is second and third,
and they're capturing
some of that value.
So a satellite is a tournament
that a certain x number
of people win a ticket
to a bigger event.
The World Series of Poker
runs a lot of satellites,
and I think these
tournaments are great,
because this is a really
difficult situation for people
to figure out, and it
causes a lot of people
to make a huge,
huge, huge mistakes.
Say this is like
100-person tournament,
where they all buy in for
like $90 or something,
such that first through
ninth gets $10,000,
and tenth place gets zero,
and there are 10 people left.
So their equity is just
their percentage chance
of winning this flat payout.
Since they all have
the same amount,
they're splitting that
$90,000 pool even, right?
So they all have approximately
the same equity, here,
because no one
gets hurt by having
more chips by the curvature.
Say they were in a situation--
blinds are $200-$400,
and Irene, here, who's
in the small blind,
raises $2,5000 to
Jessica, who has Kings.
This is one person down
until we make money.
Jessica has Kings, here.
So intuitively, what
should we do, here?
Yeah, like calling
seems not that bad.
What do I give you, here?
Like what is Jessica's range?
Jessica is pushing
anything, here, right,
because Jessica
has an M of like 3.
And she's in the small
blind, so she's appropriately
pushing any two cards,
because as we showed earlier,
you're definitely,
definitely supposed
to do that at least when
it comes to Chip-EV.
So Jessica is 82%
with the Kings,
and if we look at chip
equity, she is crushing it.
She is 82% to win
$5,000, doubling up.
She's 18% to lose.
So her equity, her expected
value after this is 4,100,
meaning her delta is 1,600.
She is expected to win
1,600 chips for this.
But what about when
we look at Dollar-EV?
We see for Dollar-EV,
she has an 82% chance
of winning $10,000 and an
18% chance of getting zero.
So her expected
value after this call
is actually $8,200,
which is worse
than her equity of
this tournament.
She actually loses money
if she makes us call.
In fact, if you put the other
person on any two cards,
you should even fold aces.
Like you should only pretend
to look at your cards
before you fold this hand.
And this is what it is for
every person in this situation,
unless you're more
than a 90% favorite
to win, which you're not,
because unless you can
particularly put them on
a hand, which you have
a Pocket-Pair that
dominates their lower,
uncorrelated cards,
you should fold.
How should this pay out?
It doesn't play out like this.
In Vegas, there's
virtually 100% chance
Jessica calls here, to
Irene and Jessica's dismay,
but to the benefit of
everyone else at the table.
But what should happen?
If you're playing
in this situation,
and everyone's
playing rationally,
how do you think this will
play out at $200-$400 blinds.
STUDENT: So Irene would
just push it, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if
you're in the big blind,
and you're pushed into,
what's your calling range?
Zero, it's 0%.
There are no cards
that you should call.
And then every single person
at that table has that 0%
calling range.
However, knowing
that your fold equity
is virtually 100%,
every single person,
at the first opportunity,
should just go all in.
Under the gun, every
single hand will open push,
and everyone else will fold.
And every single hand, that
will happen until the blinds
eventually put someone
all in against their will.
So this is a situation where
ICM comes into huge play,
like people really screw
this up, especially live.
That's why satellites are
one of my favorite types
of tournaments to play-- is
because like every idiot will
tell you that calling
with Kings here is clearly
the right move, when even
folding Aces is like way, way,
way better than
calling with anything.
You should definitely do your
best to identify opportunities
like this, because to
the extent that you
find a tournament
like this that ends up
in these types of
situations, it's
really hard for live
players to get this right.
Let's jump to late game.
Late game-- I don't have
that much to talk about.
Late game, you just have
to keep steal, re-stealing.
You're going to have
an M less than 10
probably, unless you
literally just doubled up.
Yeah?
STUDENT: What is re-stealing?
PROFESSOR: Stealing is when
you try to steal the blinds,
because they're so valuable.
Re-stealing is when
someone you identify
as stealing your blinds,
and you re-pop them
some percentage of the time.
It's like protecting your
blind, or in some cases, when
you see someone
steal before you,
and you're not
necessarily a blind,
just raising against them.
This is all going to
be pre-flop stuff.
Just be conscious of
ICM, like maybe it's
not a good time to take a
coin flip for your life.
Like don't call
with Ace-King, here,
because you have like a 2%
edge for [? a certain ?] range.
OK, so that's it for late game.
I really don't find it
to be hugely different.
Late game just plays like
a 10-handed sit-and-go.
The biggest difference is that
it's as if all the players are
playing way above their head,
because say you're bankrolled
for a $100 tournament
with 1,000 people,
and you get down to last 10.
It's now is if
you're all playing
in a $10,000 tournament.
So to some extent
that changes it up,
but it should
generally be treated
as if it is a sit-and-go that
just pays out a little bit
flatter.
That's it for tournament play.
Any questions on that?
Otherwise, we can move on
to bankroll management.
This is really the
stuff that's going to be
about poker as an investment.
So what's a bankroll?
Bankroll has a couple
different definitions.
The bankroll is like
the amount of money
you can devote to playing
poker, making poker investments.
However, like I think
it should be defined
as the amount of money
that you would have to lose
to never play poker again.
Not because you're necessarily
ashamed of how much you lost,
but because like you
lost so much money
that the stakes that you
would be required to play,
given your remaining
amount of money
would be so low that you would
never make that amount of money
back.
It's like if you can conceivably
put like $20,000 into poker,
and you lose like
$19,900, you're
not going to grind out like
one-cent, two-cent games
until you have
that $20,000 back.
You would just
stop playing poker.
You would just be like OK,
you would get a normal job
and rebuild your bankroll
through something else.
So that's how I'm
defining bankroll.
It's the amount of
money where poker
is no longer a realistic option
to be making money for you.
This only matters if
you're a winning player,
because if you're
losing player, I mean,
you should play not at all.
You should figure
out how to win,
or more accurately, you
should move down to stakes
that you're actually a winner.
That only matters
if you're winning.
The formula for
your right bankroll
doesn't work if you're
in negative expectation,
because you're eventually going
to go broke no matter what.
Some examples of what this
is-- for like a new player,
you're just going to think of
what's a lot of money to you.
If you're a new player to
poker, and you lose $10,000,
you're probably never
playing poker again.
You're a huge underdog
to ever make that up,
so that's probably the
end of your poker career,
if you're fairly new.
If you're an amateur,
realistically I
would consider your bankroll
your liquid investments-- cash
that, if you lose-- like
you shouldn't mortgage
your house-- but like
a portion of the money
you have in the bank
that if you lose,
you wouldn't be homeless
seems kind of realistic, here.
The amount of money
that you're not
investing for the long
term, but if you lost it,
and as a result, would
have to stop playing poker,
you would find that
to be reasonable.
The threshold here is like--
the bankroll management rules
are such that you're at a
2% chance of ever losing
your bankroll.
So that's a kind of ballpark
for someone who's an amateur.
And for pros, it's
all of that money,
plus as much money as
they could possibly
borrow before they get cut off.
Look, if you're
a Phil Hellmuth--
he's probably worth like
$5 million or something--
and he loses $5 million,
he's not quitting poker.
He's going to raise
another million dollars
and start playing again.
So his bankroll is probably like
$8 million before every single
person goes OK, I'm not
loaning you any money,
and then he has to get a
job at like McDonald's.
So they're in a
different situation,
and especially when we're
talking about like staking.
You can have no money and have
a bankroll of a couple hundred
grand, if you have a
track record that's
good enough that people
will just loan you money.
Let's go through some rules of
thumb for bankroll management.
This is the idea.
This was the motivation.
Someone did the math on this.
I remember checking it before.
It seemed about right.
So we're assuming a
2% chance to go broke
based on your average
buy-in, and we're assuming
you don't change stakes.
People kind of forget
what this assumption is,
so if you change stakes,
you're never going to go broke.
Why?
Because when you
lose half your money,
you're going to drop
down to half the stakes.
So like, you
asymptote near zero,
but you're never going to
actually lose all that money,
you're just going to lose a lot,
until eventually your hourly is
not worth it.
And when you go up in
stakes, it's the opposite.
Like your 2%-- -- say one the
rolls is like $100 buy-ins.
So if you have $100 buy-ins
for the main event of the World
Series-- like you have
$1 million dollars,
and then as a result of
winning that, you start playing
$50,000 buy-in tournaments,
you're not that still 2%
from the beginning to go
broke, you are now a new 2%.
So it causes a multiplying
factor if, when you win,
you take on more risk.
And the same way, if you
lose and take on less risk,
it has a dampening factor.
So this 2% is only if
you don't change stakes,
and you really should be
changing stakes, especially
because there's a high
correlation between actually
losing and not being a good
player at whatever stakes
you're playing,
and it'll give you
a chance to identify what's the
right place for you to play.
That's what the numbers are.
I'd recommend-- I happen to
play over bankroll, typically,
just because I find 2% a little
bit too-- like I wouldn't
be happy with 2% that I lost all
my money, but some people are.
I usually double these.
If you're kind of nervous
when you play poker,
it's either because you're
new, and you've never
done it before, in which
case, you'll get over it.
But if you actually
get hurt by losses,
to the point where it's
always on your mind,
it's probably because
you're not really bankrolled
appropriately.
It's because if you lost
five of those buy-ins,
you would stop
playing poker, which
meant that you
didn't really have
20 buy-ins worth of bankroll.
You only had 5.
So the theory here, it's based
on-- do you have question?
STUDENT: Yeah, when
you play a cash game,
and say you double or triple
your money, should you just
walk away, or should you just,
because you're playing well,
you have a bigger stack,
should you just keep playing?
What's the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if they're
really bad players--
This is based on average
buy-in, so basically,
if you double your
stack, and then
a lot of players at
the table also doubled,
you're playing a game
that's twice as big.
So it's not like that
makes it your normal game,
especially if they're bad.
These numbers go way down if
you're ROI goes up materially,
or your win rate.
So if you're winning a game
by a lot more than average,
you can go with fewer buy-ins.
So if you're in a situation
where the other players are
bad, I would just stay there.
If you're in a situation
that they're good,
I would, as soon as I double
up, I would change tables.
STUDENT: So it
depends on the table.
PROFESSOR: You can't take
money off a table in a casino,
but in general, I wouldn't
be too happy about having now
like more at risk than my
normal risk metrics dictate.
The theory, here, is based
on the Kelly Criterion.
Kelly was a big guy
in information theory
a couple of decades ago.
His idea is that, say you're
utility curve is logarithmic,
you maximize your
utility by betting
with regard to your edge.
For example, if
you're in a one to one
bet, where you're
60% to win, you
should bet 20% of your bankroll.
And he proves it out.
You can look up his paper.
It's pretty famous.
He's been getting a lot of
flak, because this is probably
not a great assumption,
the logarithmic utility.
So this is used in
blackjack, in particular,
where the crux of
counting cards is
that when the count
is in your favor,
you bet more, such
that eventually
your wins outpace your losses.
And then investment
management, it's
the same idea,
where you're going
to put more money
to what you consider
higher alpha-generating ideas.
The World Series of
Poker is an example
I find to be really ridiculous,
because it's like the biggest
tournament in the
world-- at least,
live-- 6,000 entries, $10,000,
like one of the biggest
entries in the world.
So the right bankroll is
like $1 million dollars
for this tournament.
And given the risk of playing
a $10,000, 6,000 person
tournament, like you're
not getting good returns
on your $1 million investment.
I always found this
to be a paradox.
For someone who actually plays
poker for money, no matter
how easy The World
Series is, you're
not getting good risk-adjusted
returns, especially when
you count overhead.
However, The World Series
of Poker, the average player
is really bad, still.
And you have good
upside in that I
think there are a lot of good
outside benefits from making
big live scores.
Like Chris Moneymaker
has made way more money
as a result of winning
the World Series
and getting these
sponsorships than he has
from actually winning, I'm sure.
And he won, I think, like
probably more than $1 million.
It wasn't huge then.
But there are a lot of
pretty big upsides there.
However, you can do-- for
the summer tournament,
I think it's very
common for pros
to do some risk
management techniques.
One is staking.
If I have an investor that
has more than $1 million,
he can allocate this to
his portfolio and stake
like 10 people and
have a little bit more
of a diversified investment.
So the common deal for
this, just so you know,
is them getting
50% of the upside.
So they get the first $10,000
and 50% of the remainder.
And to the extent that it's
a long term staking deal,
you don't get money
until they get money.
So if we play two of these,
and I lose the first one,
they get $20,000 of the second
one, plus 50% of the remainder.
That's a pretty
common staking deal.
It generally works out.
And that was, to
the extent that you
don't need to worry
about friction--
like trustworthiness--
it seems to work out
for everyone involved where
there is a lot of overhead,
but the player is grinding
out like a high dollar amount,
and the investor is getting
good diversification
to his portfolio.
And it's an equity investment--
like you don't owe this money
back if you lose it.
They're just partnering
with you in the tournament.
Something that is
more common recently
is selling shares and
trading percentages.
So this lets them create
some sort of syndicate.
I think it's all
like handshakes,
but it makes it so that
they're pretty diversified.
In addition, with regard
to outside investors,
players will just sell shares of
themselves to other investors.
They'll cut their next 10
tournaments into 10 pieces,
and they'll try to raise
like $15,000 for them,
where they sell it
off in $1,500 pieces.
So it lets a relatively
small investor
diversify across a lot
of different players.
This make a lot more sense
from a finance standpoint
in terms of you still
get this dollar amount,
but you're reducing the
variance by quite a bit.
So counter-party risk is
important, for staking,
certainly.
Like if you stake someone, and
they don't play the tournament,
or you need to worry
about them not paying you
back if they win,
that's a huge friction,
in addition to if you play in
like underground card rooms
or play online, you may
not your money back,
and you should
keep that in mind.
So if you think the club
that you pay in is 1 in 10
to get raided during
any night that you play,
you should probably reduce your
expected gross winnings by 10%
and factor that in.
The current poker environment
is-- online poker started out,
basically, back in 2003, where
The World Series of Poker
started investing a lot of
money to build up the publicity.
They invested in hold
card cams, and then
they really built it up.
And then Chris Moneymaker--
arguably the worst poker
player, yet the
most charismatic--
won the tournament.
And he was a great ambassador.
And then the following
year, someone
else who played a
satellite to get in also
won-- Brehmer, who was a pretty
good guy-- so poker blew up,
and then online poker blew up.
And it was great,
because people could
just, like your average Joe
college student could just load
like $50 on Poker Stars
and lose it to me.
So that was really good
for like five years,
and then eventually the
natural course of the game
is players get better.
Then eventually Black Friday
happened a couple years back,
where Full Tilt, one
of the poker sites,
turned out to be a Ponzi
scheme, and they actually
took everyone's money, so
anyone who had money on that
got it confiscated, and they
possibly got a percentage back,
although I'm not sure
exactly how that worked.
Then all of the poker sites
got banned from the US.
So online is kind of
gone, and like that was
a bit of a nail in the coffin.
Then poker has
contracted quite a bit.
The World Series of Poker used
to have-- you could sit down
at a table, and there would
be like six amateurs, one pro,
and two guys reading
like Poker For Dummies.
Now it's like 50-50.
Like for a $10,000 tournament,
it's still pretty soft.
But like I played
a couple years ago,
and I played in a cash game,
where 10 people at my table
were saying that they were
professional poker players.
Probably a couple were lying,
but it's much different
than it was before.
However, if you use
good game selection,
if you can find games that
are soft-- like the side
games of the World Series
are soft, and like low stakes
games are always
soft-- I find it
to be something that
could add a lot of value
to an otherwise good,
separate career,
like it diversifies
your own investments,
especially if you handle
the bankroll stuff properly.
And that's it.
So thanks a lot, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]